عندما نتحدث عن المال في كرة القدم،
هناك سمكة جديدة في البركة، وهي
سمكة كبيرة جدًا، المملكة العربية السعودية التي
يبدو أنها تنفق مئات
الملايين من الدولارات على أي لاعب
تريده، كيف غيّر ذلك
البيئة التي يتعين عليك فيها أن  تشغيل
وجهة نظري هو أنه من المهم أه أه
الحصول على مساعدة أنديتهم من الأندية
التقليدية وتحديداً الأندية
الأوروبية كما تعلم هناك
أندية أوروبية كبيرة بما في ذلك
نادي برشلونة لكرة القدم يمكنها مساعدة هذه
الفرق في الدوري السعودي للمحترفين في
من أجل إقناع بعض الاتحادات
بنقل خبرتنا ومساعدتهم على
تحسين فرقهم، أعتقد أن هذه
هي الطريقة للقيام بذلك ربما مع أكاديميات
كرة القدم ولكن في نفس الوقت مع
اتحاد مباشر من أجل تحسين
الجودة  من هذه الفرق من حيث
كرة القدم أنا أحترمك أنت تعرف
قرارات الحكومة السعودية التي
تعلم أنها تضم ​​نجوم اللاعبين الموهوبين
ولكنهم نجوم أن
كرة القدم هي رياضة رياضة جماعية كما تعلم
الأهم هو الفريق
بالطبع الذي يساعده اللاعبون الموهوبون  نحن
نروج لهذه الرياضة ونجعل
الأموال أه سعيدة لأنك تعلم أن
الموهبة هي الموهبة ولكن المهم
الفريق الفريق هو الأولوية
ومع كل الاحترام أه تفضل الذهاب إلى
المملكة العربية السعودية في الأساس ليس هناك
أسباب رياضية لك  أعلم أن هناك
أسبابًا أخرى لأن هذه هي
الأولوية ويجب أن
تكون كرة القدم هي
الأولوية